In its origins.
A liberal education always had science
in it though interestingly,
people studied science in ancient Greece
and Rome in the Middle Ages or until
very recently for precisely the opposite
reason that people are now told to study
it.
We are now tells you should study it
because it's a practical skill that you
can use in the real world.
Well,
in ancient Greece,
the practical skills that got you jobs
and got your career where rhetoric and
oratory and a study of history and law
science was seen as a kind of abstract
quest for knowledge.
The only reason you were doing it was
mental stimulation and yet for hundreds
and hundreds of years people studied
science really just to try to answer the
big questions.
There was no sense that it could be
applied in a way that was practical,
would provide you with a career.
That's a very modern conception of
science and so I think what's
interesting is that even then when we
thought science was useless,
we studied it used us in a practical
sense.
Today my argument will be yours.
Think about that length and breadth of
history.
When you say their English is useless.
Yale has opened a campus in Singapore
and what they've done is they've tried
to reimagine what a liberal education
would look like.
Uh,
and they've also tried to reimagine what
it would look like in a global context.
There is a core that for the first two
years there is a series of required
courses.
Uh,
but the requirements are more in method
of inquiry that is in critical thinking
rather than in a particular subject or a
particular set of books.
You Study Aristotle,
but at the same time you read Confucius
who was aristotle's contemporary and you
ask yourself,
why did aristotle have certain concerns
about politics?
But Confucius had others.
What explains this difference?
So the idea here would be to try to
understand that the west is not the only
thing in the world,
that there is a much broader universe
and you understand the differences and
similarities.
All these subjects have deep a long
traditions and feed various parts of the
human brain and the human soul.
And so recognize that what seems
fashionable when one Arrow will not seem
fashionable in another,
but they all together interact and
comprise a liberal education.